Germany will take its turn in the
European elections on Sunday and so far
Chancellor Angela Merkel has mostly
stayed out of the campaign there is
concern however that Marco could damage
the prospects of her party the Christian
Democrats as well as her successor to
the head of the party Europe's most
powerful woman also used to be the
poster girl for her conservative CDU
party in EU elections but that's history
this time Angela Merkel left the EPP s
widely unknown top candidate man played
me by mostly out alone to face the
public and it was Mackel successor as
CDU party leader and a great camp Karin
Bauer who many already see as potential
next Chancellor who took on the heavy
political lifting in the talk shows
India tarts in search for US
conservatives right-wing populist are
not potential coalition partners we
don't want to and we won't work with
them with nothing less than the future
of Europe at stake this raises the
question where was Angela Merkel
busy governing is the shorter answer
with an EU summit in Romania a climate
dialogue in Berlin and a trip to Africa
Mackel focused on big-picture politics
one of her few appearances with the EPP
stop candidate man quit Weber was in
Croatia where she took a stance against
nationalism patriotism and the EU and
contradictions nationalism is the enemy
of the European project we must make
that clear in these final days ahead of
the polls the social democrat top
candidate tells us Markos absence is
also a symptom of inner party divisions
I think it's honest that you have the
European candidates on the in the
campaign and not the national figures on
the other hand you see that the
Conservatives are really split Europe's
longest-serving MEP Mr pork insists
there was simply a division of labour
variable news from Chancellor and party
leader share responsibility for the
results no ducking away Angela Merkel
and an elite camp Karen Bauer know that
their current division of power between
the Chancellery and the party
headquarters can't last forever though
publicly both say they are determined to
continue until 2021 when MCOs final term
as Chancellor officially ends these EU
elections will tell us more about the
chances of an agreed camp Kevin Bauer to
also succeed Angela Merkel here in the
Chancery than about the stability of the
current final makkal led government
itself but they're an important test for
both